je crois qu'on est parti est-ce que vous
allez bien est ce que ça marche dit moi
si tout va bien pour vous est ce que ça
fonctionne nous et il ya du son j'ai
l'impression qu'on a un petit bug dans
titre du truc
dites moi tout est ce que vous
m'entendez vous me voyez ça marche oui
non alors alors alors alors j'ai lancé
le stream les amis est ce que vous voyez
ce que vous m'entendez on va se faire
les tests de l'autre côté c'est bon vous
voyez ça lui aurélien salut à tous
et dites-moi est-ce que le son est bien
en phase avec la vidéo il n'y a pas de
décalage
tout marche bien il ya pas de souci
ouais ça fonctionne 505 tout va bien
génial parce que c'est un tout nouveau
c'est top je tente des nouveaux trucs
pour deal extreme et je suis pas
forcément hyper hyper à l'aise alors on
va se mettre tout de suite sur le live
stream 2 au nord
je compte sur vous pour me dire si ça
fonctionne le son on va se regarder les
nouveautés alors attendez tak tak
monsieur refait ses tests en même temps
qu'il vous parle je ne vous raconte pas
l'histoire
est ce que vous entendez le son la garde
et on va se remettre
on va switcher de ce côté là dites moi
si vous entendez bien ouais alors on va
se regarder le live stream doit y avoir
plein de choses à voir il ya des
nouveautés pendant que je suis avec vous
je regarde ça parce qu'il ya des choses
qui t'a qu est-ce que j'ai tout je
voulais discuter en même temps comme ça
je suis un peu je fais un peu ma peau
potes de mon côté je finis tout vous
préparez tout vous installez voilà
là on s'organise on s'installe on est
bien va y avoir plein de choses à voir
vous n'avez pas de son vous avez le son
de la vidéo pas attendez si vous n'avez
pas le fond de la vidéo
[Musique]
baisse
est ce que vous entendez ou à la baisse
[Musique]
something pantxika tu le sauras ici
volaille a trop alors attendez vous
inquiétez pas là dessus
pour l'instant on va ce n'est pas trop
fort on va regarder up
attendez je suis nîmes organisé pendant
que je suis avec vous je vous raconte
pas l'histoire c'est une grande
nouveauté pour moi de faire ça comme ça
c'est juste voilà donc ça ça fonctionne
voilà sa récente à découvrir donc offrir
le fait ensemble qu'à faire sans les
secours
[Musique]
alors ce monsieur qui gère tout comme ça
à la dérive entre mon pas comment
[Musique]
yes yes yes j'arrive larijani
voilà on serait ça comme ça hop voilà
comme ça on va être pas mal tout dire
trente mille choses en même temps le
temps que tout ça démarre tranquillement
[Musique]
wade n'a dit que c'est un peu c'est quoi
c'est mon sont à moi ou alors c'est le
son de au nord dites moi ça lag
alors est-ce que ça doit être le son de
la vidéo on va regarder ça est ce que
vous l'avez le son de la vidéo en même
temps là tout de suite où vous
l'entendez ou pas le son de la vidéo est
trop fort la vidéo lag
bon on est bien tout va bien est ce que
vous m'entendez est ce que le son de ma
voix dans les gds un peu le son d'avoine
est ce que le 100 ma voix ça va mieux
comme ça est ce que c'est un peu moins
fort
les deux hoquets le sonder au nord le
son de honor pour l'instant il est
baissé vous devriez pas l'avoir tout de
suite le son de au nord vous devriez
avoir que moi leçon laguiller le son est
trop fort alors j'ai baissé mon son côté
au niveau des vies mais normalement ça
doit aller un petit peu mieux la vidéo
la ghandi fps des fps normalement là
j'ai la fibre derrière il ya tout ce
qu'il faut ça doit le faire le son est
bien et la vidéo n'est pas fluide 1 1
enfin
ok ça marche merci pour vos retours
bon on va essayer de se mettre le
livestream avec honor derrière et dites
moi si ça fonctionne comme ça si ça va
pour vous alors là je vais remettre le
son pop s'en est ému live stream 1 m3
font sans escale paris si je peux monter
là je me montre et c'est une chose mais
est-ce que vous m'entendez bien ouais
elle n'est pas fluide ça j'ai la fille
parce que ça devient de votre côté je
sais pas du tout moi je regarde sur mon
moniteur ça a l'air d'aller à peu près
un plat comme ça j'aime me le mettre sur
mon iphone je l'avais en même temps et
je pourrai voir ce que vous voyez vous à
peu près ok
à
hélas comme ça
on entend bien ta bois merci beaucoup
aprilia ça c'est très très cool très
content on s'entendait bien moi c'était
un peu un peu la guerre alors s'il ya un
aspirateur en fait c'est pas un
aspirateur
c'est mon macbook qui carbure à fond et
qui du coup c'est effectivement un peu
le bruit d'aspirateur faut que je les
retire un peu le micro comme ça je peux
m'en derrière et non maintenant vous
avez moins le four du dih macbook alors
la presse elle va commencer là d'ici
très peu de temps il va avoir toutes les
nouveautés voir tout ce qu'il en est
alors laissez-moi voir on va craquer ça
alors
kim en même temps soit elle vous voyez
en train d'écouter effectivement ça
favori bruit d'aspirateur l'ordinateur
là je vais reconnaître que c'est ça ou
huit mois de mars
malheureusement pour moi j'ai déjà les
attend si votre passé ont plus que vous
avez des sommes remises
je disais que dans la description de la
vidéo vous avez avec un code si ça vous
intéresse sur plein de produits de la
gamme au nord vous avez sur le horn
petit rôle au nord ne pas enfin il ya
plein de produits ou allez-vous vous
dirai pas que vous verrez dans la vidéo
il en ressort cependant également bien
là je viens la guinée va coûter merci
pour tous vos économies attendues
laissez moi juste choquée comme ça je
vais me rendre compte que
[Musique]
effectivement c'est très très fort là
normalement ça devrait aller un petit
peu mieux
comme je suis comme vous imaginez en
décalé donc j'arrive pas forcément brand
content donc je me rends compte sur mon
petit moniteur ce qui se passe en direct
ah ouais et en plus moi ok alors
attendez on va essayer de faire ça un
petit peu mieux la pop la normale à les
amis si je regarde bien là j'ai le chat
en plus ce qui est sûr ma tronche donc
tout va bien on va essayer de réajuster
ça je vais me mettre en haut à droite et
normalement je devrais plus avoir le
chat sur la tête et voir voilà on
n'arrête pas le progrès alors on remet
le son du live stream camp l'ont pas
quand même ce qui se passe ça serait un
peu mal au sérieux le marché
ok ça fonctionne bon voilà dites moi si
ça fonctionne pour vous c'est
un petit peu vos commentaires tout ce
que vous me racontez plein de choses
intéressantes au nord ces chinois rui au
nord bien évidemment c'est une marque
chinoise
qu'est-ce qu'on est debout qu'est ce que
vous dites moi vous allez bien dites moi
vous ça va ça se passe bien comment ça
va pour vous en ce moment bien vous êtes
dans quel coin d'ailleurs marqué le mois
en bas dans les temps que ça n'a pas
commencé
on va se mettre comme ça voilà vous êtes
dans quel coin alors allez-y mark et moi
tout ça c'est du pin dieu des téléphones
mais pas des live mais il ya encore du
progrès à faire mais on va y arriver sur
les lives on va y arriver
je compte sur vous pour me dire si tout
va bien ou s'il ya des petits soucis je
vous cache pas que c'est pas hyper hyper
encore évident pour me rendre compte du
tout comme ça mais on va y arriver
alors attendez j'ai l'impression que ça
commence voyons voir ce qui se passe
au nord nice dites moi s'ils sont du
stream est suffisamment fort je voyais
un point de temps tahiti et du monde
damien bretagne vous êtes de partout
l'algérie anglet nord booba et dubaï
vous êtes vraiment de partout ouais
mayenne bretagne alors belgique de revin
ce zèle de partout
est ce que vous l'avez bien le son de la
vidéo de honor là comme ça a commencé
et
est ce que vous entendez bien le live à
la vidéo de honor vous la donner ou pas
on n'entend pas régi monter un petit peu
gaming et novartis
est ce que ça mange de la france j'ai
monté le son du lay your highness live
et à demain en tête basse et est passé à
100 m en 9 ans de passion mais ce matin
on peut même pas si celui-ci moi je
ferai des vos questions vous parlez pas
anglais
alors je vais essayer de regarder le
solaire en fait il ya toute une partie
où il est en train de parler de la
management c'est donc là il vous paraît
effectivement peu du marché du haut des
tronçons comme ça ça vaut le coup est
parti tout oppose parlons de la série
contre 30 que le vendra pas encore testé
d'ailleurs et on va parler dans neuf
acquis le sujet qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui est on
beaucoup en parler alors vous le
traduire ça c'est mon mac qui fait ce
bruit de ventilateurs m'éloigner un peu
comme ça lâche le mac j'ai pas 30 degrés
l'après midi
chez obs pour ce qu'il aime pas mais il
sous titré ça va être compliqué vous
voyez en font tout un topo sur la marque
attendez je vais me mettre sur le jeu
suivant le type comme vous sur direct au
bon c'est une marque numéro 10 mars en
russie je pense que ça vous fait une
belle jambe même si effectivement ça
permet de voir la progression est une
marque de la santé des jeunes majeurs
jeunes actifs étudiants
c'est vraiment la cible de 2 au nord il
a effectivement de tout oppose sur le
marché sait pas si ça vous passionne
tout en étant des femmes en bas dont
celle ci fasse marrer c'est bon là
effectivement il fatto sur la russie
donc je sais pas si vous êtes en russie
et si effectivement l'un des marchés de
la russie vous intéresse pas mais en
tout cas c'est un col eu le toupet tout
de suite
huawei honor ils travaillent ensemble en
fait c'est là c'est la même marque saint
honoré huawei sont rattachés tout ça est
rattachée aux petits nains comme ça tu
es meilleur merci c'est toi le meilleur
en les services de google sur les odeurs
de force avec un choix qui a été fait
bien par huawei justement non sur tous
les nouveaux smartphones de l'élève à
voir les
service les hms by service vous n'aurez
donc pas inquiet google les samedis
google sur les 1000 aux smartphones mais
vous aurez labial alors là nous parle du
aux nomades ou que je voulais déjà
présenté notamment jack vraiment lui et
les hypra intéressant on en reparlera
duo no magic book moi je trouve ça
vraiment bien c'est un très bon
ordinateur c'est que paris reichert très
abordable est-ce que ça va comme ça
équilibre des soins entre - d'un côté
entre au nord de l'autre news est un
petit jeu c'est d'être là est-ce que ça
va arriver
elle est détenue pour l'otan vous
l'entendez pas c'est mignot tout un
message vous êtes j'ai lu que les
encouragements et vos messages soient
vraiment roulements violence en un
mais à part cela comme ça parfait c'est
bien super on touchera un équilibre tout
va bien ouvrir vers la techno alors vous
voyez ce kimono ne pas revivre une
partie sur un sur le marché voir entrer
effectivement tout à l'heure dans
parlons du n 9 comme il est et il n'y a
pas des choses à raconter des leviers
rapide bir
vous avez des vip chez moi toujours
regarder
xavier agréé loger tous voté à regarder
[Musique]
c'était un samedi comme ça d'abord le 18
juin au 1er juillet faisant enregistrer
sur le site aux lyonnais et comme je
suis un gunner dans la description du
jour là il veut vous pouvez vous nous
donnerez vous êtes un code de 20%
utilisé sur plein de vidéos york à
vérifier dans la description les jetons
qui pédalent parce que je sais c'est
très intéressant ce qu'il me voulait
acquérir un nouveau produit au nord
c'est un peu d'argent la peinture garder
l'on parle de la france faisant à partir
du 26 ans très cool son avocate me last
but not least en est un autre
[Applaudissements]
après avoir passé le macbook vous aurez
montrer le produit vous vouliez vraiment
l'écosystème entre aux côtés de magic
bâtiments connectés et se tord les
smartphones c'est vraiment la stratégie
sur un écosystème complet si vous avez
suivi ce que fait ouailles ont consacré
au nord là dessus on fait cela et ils
ont vraiment rose stratégie d'écosystème
et vous allez voir
simplifié au fur et à mesure plus qu'un
autre
60% en prison
[Musique]
et
magic mirrors et qu'on ne pourra en
parler
[Musique]
la main
c'est pas une période de jeu pas le
terme nous permet dans le nord si vous
n'êtes pas sur la partie produits
je suis d'accord avec toi qu une photo
ou une caméra était ravi allez savoir
eni s'est bien évidemment produit
contestera plus tard je vous invite à
vous abonner c'est à dire que c'était
pour garder avec nous à l'escouade mars
à 15 heures de vidéos seront 10 33
heures c'est une actrice x à ses grands
espaces omar halli pas une seconde cinq
heures des vidéos sur le tas de vos yeux
mais en tout cas plutôt bien très grosse
batterie
c'est vraiment voyez il commence à faire
un focus tu as tu n'es pas sur cette
partie des taux d'audience parce que
c'est un point essentiel aujourd'hui
veut pas des smartphones comparaison
contentons pas dans un cube
mais je vais les wc 185 grammes c'est
vraiment un produit qui est très les
yeux ça c'est aussi très très cool mon
pensons j'ai monté mon congé des selles
soin de l'autre et vous m'entendez pas
que ça sature en fait qu est-ce que vous
m'entendez comme sa literie moins bien
un produit qui est très fin c'est cool
autant
bravo on y est super ce notre caméra
donc effectivement il n'ya pas de module
photo qui dépasse à l'arrière donc ça
veut dire pas un smartphone qui va être
pas branquignols mais qui va obliger
potentiellement offrir une talent ça
c'est très cool
alors rien la prise jack effectivement
si vous voulez bien brancher des
écouteurs dedans pour la partie audio
ça c'est très très cool qu'est-ce que
vous utilisez vous les prises jack c'est
un truc qui vous intéressent est ce que
vous avez comme moi un casque comme ça
la voyez avec une bonne vieille priziac
c'est quelque chose que vous utilisez
uniquement dans le chat etc c'est à dire
en commentaire mais dans le chatt
chiffré kurun versailles moi j'étais
déjà que moi 6,3 pouces
on est sur un nuage des eaux n'est pas
sur du full hd avoir effectivement lors
du test ne reparlera on a effectivement
on parle j'ai racheté un haut parleur
boulot avec moi williston 6.0 pour tout
ça on regardera lors du test qu'on fera
très très très très très prochainement
alors là on a quoi une caméra celle pour
la profondeur de champ d'un ultra
grand-angle de 5 mégapixels une caméra
principale de 13 mégapixels f 1.8 voyez
c'est un combo qui est classique en fait
le fait d'avoir un ultra grand angle et
le fait d'avoir la 2 mégapixels pour le
mode portrait ça marche très très bien
c'est pas mal ça c'est joli ça na waie
ils ont fait montre en huit et demi en
fait c'est vraiment le très lourd et
focus qui était fait mention voyez
toujours le manteau au combat en fait ya
toujours de menton va c'est une
technologie d'écran si vous voulez parce
que si vous voulez avoir un écran qui va
juste d'en bas sanaa un peu compliqué à
faire explique vous montrer mais ça
coûte un peu plus cher à fabriquer et ça
leur coûte un peu moins chasse afin de
sortir des tarifs un peu plus un peu
plus bas 512 giga de stockage c'est de
la boucherie de la malouine très grosse
batterie très gros stockage axa s'est
effectivement de pouvoir naître alors
expendables dont vous permettez je casse
à 120 gigas des cartes sim cartes
microsd classique ça marche
c'est un combo qui fonctionne
il nous faut tout un petit un petit topo
sur la la qualité du produit la
durabilité du produit pourrait
effectivement c'est un produit qui va
durer et qu'on n'est pas du tout sur un
truc pas se garer bord quality test
est-ce que vos sorties
[Musique]
dorothée est en face à peu près cinq ans
a le temps de test tout la voile en
tchat
pour fasse tomber des territoires dafoe
et qu'on voit ceux qui hésitent parce
que j'ai durabilité
à pâques
et pas
[Musique]
sacré gros caucus pour montrer
effectivement la chaîne ten dam à noter
qu'en achetant un produit bio nord va
pouvoir résister aux conditions extrêmes
dans l'équipe et il m'en vais pas le
mettre dans la neige mais c'est vraiment
pour nous aurons
ça va fort qu'eux
[Musique]
c'est toujours une terre efficace dans
ses vidéos de marketing c'est une terre
différents interlocuteurs
enfin gros focus au visage avec la
partie photo
[Musique]
drop est trop cool regardez ça on risque
de casser des trajectoires faudra
regarder tout c'est magique tu vois
ajouté magic soyons va avoir sur
l'android disent ok et là effectivement
on parle disent qu'ils s'appellent
riccione score c'est lé web au bail
service isu effectivement on n'a pas les
services de google
on a les services de huawei avec toutes
les applications dans la vie à la vie et
vous voyez ici
alors là c'est vraiment une conférence
globale donc vous n'allez pas avoir la
spécificité des produits défectueux en
france mais en france vous avez quand
même pas mal de choses a dit ça va finir
c'est au fait qu'on devrait avoir d'être
flic normalement je sais pas si c'est
encore si c'est arrivé ou pas mais je
regarde y'a un coyote c'est pas mal de
choses j'en ai déjà parlé sur la vidéo
de la galerie et jeter un coup d'oeil
vous verrez ça la braderie c'est une
attitude qui vachement intéressante
parce que même si aujourd'hui cinq ans
par trouver tout ce qu'on a sur les
services de google sur le playsport il
est par contre normale deltaméthrine y
développe il y aurait une solution qui
est intéressante pour moi la concurrence
est toujours donne donc je pense que ça
va être vraiment vraiment un thalassa
sexe salue une nouvelle personne qui
vient d'arriver saliou sène je partirai
arrivée nous avons tiré cap de la fiche
technique
ouais on est sur un produit les use et
abuse 676 on est sur un produit d'entrée
mis le biam mais là d'être assez honnête
en tout cas il ya un vrai gros focus qui
était fait sur l'autonomie et ça ça va
être extrêmement important et qu'une
batterie comme ça qu'est ce qui démontre
là
matisse art est dans le chat de faire de
la pub mattuse l'école matisse
c'est marrant voyez tout ce travail qui
est fait entre la mode elle les marques
ça crée de la valeur supplémentaire sur
ce côté hyper hyper trendy vous et
descend à l'évidence très masculine donc
je sais pas si ça qui s'est trop votre
truc mais c'est marrant ça la pochette
pour ranger votre ordinateur au nord
hyper classe ils cherchent vraiment
envoyé à avoir un autre public
là ils veulent féminise féminiser le
leur clientèle et la voyance ouagadougou
qui commence à me parler de microsoft on
leur parlera parce qu'un plein de choses
à raconter de plus extrêmement
intéressant sur ce produit
on en parlera un peu plus tard
d'ailleurs je compterai sur vous pour
être présent à ce moment là voyez sans
microsoft 365 on en reparlera ça c'est
vraiment vraiment intéressant je sais
pas si vous avez regardé mon test du
nord magic bout qu'ils ont fait un ordi
qui est extrêmement intéressant à un
tarif de ouf une machine qui marche très
très bien
alors vous n'allez pas faire du montage
vidéo vous n'êtes pas faire des choses
complètement dingue dessus mais pour de
la bureautique pour de la prise de notes
pour du travail pourquoi de la
collaboration pour plein de choses
vous pouvez vraiment le faire c'est
super cool
ce n'est pas la pochette moi j'aime bien
[Musique]
la pochette est bi mais non ce n'est pas
une peu ses tipis l'envahisseur je
comprends matisse mais tu si tu t'en
mets beaucoup quand même
[Musique]
madier quoi de deux très cool vous en ai
déjà parlé aussi c'est vraiment
intéressant tout ce qu'on voit là c'est
la vision de l'écosystème avec vous
savez on est sur ce que vous retrouve
d'autres marques avec d'un côté le
smartphone de l'autre côté la montre
connectez vous allez faire du sport ça
c'est bien ça s'allume annuelle ça vas y
toi est-ce que vous avez vous un
ordinateur de veau d'or est ce que vous
l'avez acheté le magic book est ce que
ces choses qui pourraient vous tenter
c'est une alternative qui vraiment
vraiment intéressante
voyez on parle vraiment des usages en
parle vraiment de l'usaj sport c'est
tout l'idée de ces montres connectés
alors regardez la vidéo
[Musique]
c'est toujours difficile ce qui nous
font en vidéo marketing comme ça cet
automne les belles voitures
ça c'est un produit avec l'auto l'onu
absolument incroyable
[Musique]
quoi
ça
[Musique]
bon vraiment sur les usages de la moins
connectée est ce que vous en cuisine
certes wesh
pour moi c'est vraiment des usages sport
dessus et effectivement il ya eu celle
du quotidien avec le calendrier commun
des choses mais à chaque fois les
marques confondues gros usage sur toute
la partie sport et on voit que c'est
vraiment ça en fait
vidéos de concerts filmés dans les amis
de lomagne la réponse est pas impossible
peut-être peut-être jardiner mais pareil
le bracelet le bracelet est les raccords
au niveau de la pochette et au niveau du
bracelet donc là vous avez toutes les
applis de sport je voulais déjà montré
dans la vidéo je vous invite à aller la
découvrir si ce produit vous intéresse
et a maintenant on parle des magic idir
boys toujours une fois de plus dans
l'idée de l'écosystème et c'est ça qui
est intéressant avec honor et de la
stratégie au norway c'est que il ya
vraiment une
une frontière entre toute la partie
android et eux ce qu'ils proposent voyez
on arrive vraiment dans une troisième
solution viable qui se développe et
c'est très intéressant à voir comment ça
va continuer dans le temps une réduction
de bruit active je suis drôle trembler
la réduction de bruit active
à la vidéo
[Musique]
oui
la changement de colorimétrie d'un
coureur n'est pas fou on essayait le
brut est stressant on est hyper détendu
le jour où y en a un qui me fait ça dans
le métro à paris
je dirais pas je me coupe une mais je
serais très surpris en tout cas fb oui
[Musique]
ce gain la colorimétrie de l'image
concept est très jolie alors on est
vraiment sur lui ils ont fait ressortir
le bleu en fait dans la dans l'image moi
j'adore le bleu on le voit à la regarder
ma part tous ces bleus derrière il ya un
filtre bleu ya du bleu tous les côtés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
regardez on vous le montre la les
démonstrations la preuve par la
démonstration
c'est ce qu'il faut toujours c'est pas
mal ce petit bleu là vous aimez moi je
vois pas mal
il faut de plus fut bleus bon là j'ai
pas de bleus sur moi mais jamais en bleu
c'est très pop
regardez comment elle habillée entre les
couleurs seront rouges un peu toniques
ce bleu turquoise genou fera engueuler
par ma femme elle me direz c'est pas du
bleu est un turquoise
c'est très très tonique et une fois de
plus en reste dans l'idée du de la cible
jeune avec un produit jeunes très
dynamique écosystèmes voyez il ya le mot
on nous le dit
condé dans l'écosystème très clairement
on aime le bleu c'est vrai beau le vrai
on aime le bleu hop là je me change et
meurent bas
un traitement du mexique
alors c'est vrai que des fois il ya des
couleurs qu'on voit sur des lancements
globale comme ça qu'on retrouve pas
forcément france une fois de plus vous
avez milliards dans la description a
répliqué comme ça vous verrez toutes les
nouveautés et nouveaux produits et des
fois il ya certaines couleurs qui sont
réservées à certains marchés mais là ce
bleu il nous le faut son économie
très cool jusqu'à 24 heures découle de
musique
voyez on peut être plus le gros focus
qui est fait sur le sur l'autonomie on
l'avait sur le smartphone avec la
batterie de 5 millions paire eur / leur
honneur de fa là on le voit également au
niveau de l'autonomie pouvoir profiter
complètement de sa musique partout et où
est ce que vous êtes
on la rentrée dans le côté technique la
réduction de bruit active pour vos
appels
ça c'est important guillaume et salut ça
va mon bon ami
pas mal dites moi ce que vous en pensez
vous voyez on recommence l'écosystème la
monte les écouteurs on a donc en être ou
à l'airless ir bud il vous avait les
magic eagles
c'est vraiment une gamme qui se
complètent on le voit de plus en plus
avec les magic book eléonore 9 ha dont
on a effectivement ce gros lancement en
envoyer on a un produit on à
l'écosystème qui continue à se dessiner
tout autour de ça oui je vais faire une
vidéo sur l'odeur de fin on en parle ici
quelques jours elle manque de champagne
cette conférence a c'est mon pote
guillaume ca1 et guillaume du champagne
viens viens on t'attend membres
devraient bientôt à paris que voir le
prix le prix le prix galien droite
ténois 149 euros qui dit mieux voyez le
placement le positionnement c'est très
très très agressif et une fois de plus
un tarif qui vous intéressent vous avez
20 % de plus là dessus
autant vous dire que c'est pas cadeau
mais presque madge un bouton spécial
bundle très attention on en reparle du
magic bout prochainement le voir c'est
extrêmement agressif normalement
649 euros 649 euros 649 bon extrêmement
sérieuses et c'est tout le
positionnement de toutes façons de honor
d'abord positionnement est vraiment
vraiment agressif pas agressif envers
vous envers la concurrence pour vous
emmener à venir dans l'écosystème à
découvrir leurs services à découvrir
leurs produits bien de people très
efficace très très efficace
petit récap de produits à ce petit
turquoise paridis bleu turquoise le cul
tu mens on a complete là
c'est acquis et que je crois parce que
vous savez quand on va sur des
lancements de produits comme ça eh bien
on a toujours la pause était de prendre
des produits de pouvoir les prendre en
main les découvrir et là malheureusement
et ben non
voilà c'est fini hop on repasse ici
écoutez c'était vraiment très très cool
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
s'il ya un produit qui vous a un peu
hype est plus qu'un autre on va rester
encore un tout petit peu ensemble on va
en profiter donc on est là on est bien
gardère hop là je coupe tout voilà on
regarde que le son on est entre nous je
vous invite une fois de plus à attendait
tant que je me remets au bon endroit
j'ai tellement de fenêtre je sais même
plus où j'en suis c'est ça de faire un
live stream avec un macbook pro ne pas
avoir deux moniteurs tous les côtés on a
tout seul au même endroit c'est un peu
la galère
alors dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez parce qu'effectivement vin qu'on
a eu cet écosystème avec d'un côté le
honor 9a on a d'un autre côté le magic
book dont je vous ai déjà parlé on voit
qu'on a effectivement lors smartwatch on
voit qu'on a des solutions avec des
écouteurs on voit qu'on a une gamme qui
se dessine de plus en plus et à mon avis
ça va continuer et en terme d' usage
c'est surtout ça qui est intéressant
c'est vous qu'est ce que vous allez
pouvoir en faire parce que si vous avez
sur le téléphone
on s'en doute pour pouvoir passer des
coups de fil on va pas avoir le
smartphone le plus puissant avec le
médiathèque on a derrière mais par
contre tous les jeux je dirais que vous
allez pouvoir avoir sans forcément faire
tourner un portail dessus qui
fonctionnera pas mais voyez plein de
petits jeux iront très bien avec une
très grosse autonomie c'est au
paramétrage d'emmener partout tout le
temps avec vous ça c'est bien le fait
d'avoir la prise jack 3.5 ça c'est aussi
intéressant pour pouvoir brancher votre
casque et ça devient de plus en plus
rare bien que dans le segment entrée
milieu de gamme on en trouvera dans
quelques-uns on n'a pas la meilleure
définition d'écran on n'est pas sur du
full hd on est sur du hd en 1600 par 720
pixels
mais bon avoir avoir ce canal est bien
faite et bien qui a livré ses propres
intérêts sans haut parleur mono mais
c'est normal on a une caméra principale
de 13 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 1.8 on a
un ultra grand-angle de 5 mégapixels la
caméra de 2 mégapixels qui est là pour
le mode portrait pour les faits évoqués
bon moi je trouve qu'on a un équilibre
qui est quand même plutôt bien très
raisonnable surtout le tarif 149 euros
c'est extrêmement agressif et je vous le
dis une fois de plus vous avez 20 % de
remise d'un moral et ça dure
3 juin donc vous pouvez y aller dès
maintenant s'il vous intéresse vous
emilien dans la description jusqu au 1er
juillet vous avez 20 % de remise sur le
honor 9,6 pro dont on a déjà parlé le au
nord 9 à léonore magic herbays honor
magic watch 2 series on est déjà
également parlé est due aux normes
éthiques book 14 pouces vous aimez le
code en basset en majuscule à v ip
vieilles pies fr e vip fr
c'est plutôt cool le fait surtout
d'avoir à ce tarif là je dis si vous
voulez un produit au nord c'est
maintenant parce que c'est extrêmement
agressif d'accord dites moi vous en
commentaire est ce que vous avez des
questions ou interrogations suggestions
pour moi une fois de plus on reste
vraiment sur l'idée de l'écosystème sur
le fait de pouvoir tout faire
fonctionner ensemble très facilement de
façon complètement transparente et en
plus vous pouvez venir avec votre
smartphone piloter votre magic book
je voulais déjà présenté notamment sur
les services de huawei avec un dans les
pc là je voulais également montré sur le
pc de honor et c'est très très cool
alors dites-moi est-ce que vous avez des
questions des choses quand on regarde ça
ensemble
alors c'est une presse de au nord donc
on va parler d'eux au nord a souhaité
aussi manqué des questions sur d'autres
produits mais combien vont coûter les
écouteurs effectivement la pam et
cliquez sur le lien dans la description
et je pense qu'on aura tous plutôt
intéressant et 7 et cost est accessible
aux déficients visuels
c'est une très bonne question cédric je
me vois je pourrais pas te répondre
le processeur j'ai pas vu c'est un
processeur médiathèque on rentrera dans
détaillé lors de la vidéo donne boxing
normalement elle devrait arriver tout
début juillet probablement le 1er
juillet donc abonnez-vous s'est pas déjà
le cas comme ça vous saurez tout
alors quand les gens regardent un petit
peu toutes vos questions c'est quoi le
tonneau me de la montre la montre a eu
très très très grosse autonomie je crois
qu'on n'est pas loin de la semaine mais
j'ai pas vous dire de bêtises retournez
voir ma vidéo de test vous avez sur ma
chaîne vous avez dans la playlist monde
connecté ça doit être une des dernières
monde si ce n'est la nar monde connecté
que j'ai testé comme ça vous saurez tout
laissez moi regardez qu'est ce que vous
marquez on va attendre que le prix
baisse alors le prix baissera un moment
ou un autre mais là déjà avec 20% de
remise sur tout l'écosystème
croyez moi que ça vous fait vraiment
baisser le prix donc si toutefois vous
êtes intéressés par ces produits et que
c'est le moment de changer pour vous je
pense que c'est une belle opportunité
jusqu'à début juillet pas de norme ip67
non parce qu'en fait cédric tu sais que
le fait d'avoir une norme ip ça coûte à
peu près 20 25 euros ou dollars je sais
plus par produit donc ça augmenterait le
prix du produit et sa raisons pour
lesquelles les produits d'entrée milieu
de gamme n'ont pas de certification
lippé que soit ip67 ou ip68 le dommage
qu'il n'y ait pas de type c vous voyez
c'est une grosse batterie de 5 millions
terreur mais une fois de plus je pense
que c'est une question pour réduire les
coûts et vous sortir un produit un tarif
très intéressant
alors attendez attendez attendez connoté
disponible sur la galerie coyote est
disponible sur la galerie ouais ça fait
une annonce qui a été faite par obama il
ya déjà un petit moment fallu retrouver
son problème
la montre au nord c'est la même que la
web j'étais de moyens très très
similaires extrêmement similaires 5000
en perdant ses larges ouïes carrément
salut brandon bonjour bonjour à toi
aussi je veux être modo une petite
prochaine fois
il y aura un oeil d'or vieux 30
on reparlera d'autres produits d honorer
prochainement tu es à la bourre avec le
chat ouais ouais malheureusement c'est
un chat en direct et puis le temps que
je lise ya le décalage du streaming
en plus je passe par un boîtier
d'acquisition vidéo je vous fais un peu
l'histoire voilà c'est un petit peu long
mais je vous réponds je vous réponds que
c'est plus important quand même il coûte
combien alors si on parle effectivement
du smartphone et coûte 149 euros et une
fois de plus avec les 20% de remise vous
y gagner encore un petit peu ça vous le
passez à 110 120 130 par la 120-110 le
mec qui est bourbach allez hop calculé
direct la main voilà bon je regarde un
petit peu ça va vous allez bien ça se
passe bien sinon ouais le prix de la
montre
le prix de la manche je te la donne dans
ma vidéo de la montre ou s'ils n'ont pas
le lien dans la description tu peux
cliquer tu as tous les produits du au
nord sur leur site et à ce moment là tu
pourra effectivement voir le prix de la
montre
voilà un petit peu ok bon pendant que
emile nous laisse des lettres que je ne
semblerait pas dans une vidéo des odeurs
il coûte combien je veux déjà tout dit
ok bon bah écoute et voilà merci à vous
jeter très heureux ça fait une heure
qu'on est ensemble sur ce live stream
premier live stream avec la config que
j'ai là actuellement il a fallu tout
assembler tous montés pour vous proposer
ça va y avoir encore des ajustements à
faire mais c'est un très bon début je
suis très content de le faire avec vous
dites moi si ça vous convient si ça vous
va si la qualité était au rendez vous si
ça vous a plu et surtout ce que vous
pensez des produits des odeurs et quant
à lyon se trouve extrêmement rapidement
pour continuer à parler tech et croyez
moi
mais croyez moi il ya plein de belles
choses qui arrivent nous envoient
beaucoup d'amour a très vite
tintin